[Music]
chuck
yes what time of day is the sun
the highest in the sky
no i don't know high noon i knew yeah i
knew
and unless it's daylight savings time
and then it's like one o'clock
okay uh what's the hottest time of day
normally around three o'clock why isn't
it when the sun is at its highest
why are you doing this to me just trying
to
what is this
in your face
no let me think here um when the sun is
at its highest point in the sky it is
maximally heating
the earth in that well then that makes
sense because if it's at that point that
it starts to maximally heat the earth
then it would take a little longer for
the earth to actually no that don't make
no sense i'll take it back
uh i'm trying to think here why would it
be because every moment after that it's
heating the earth less that's all i'm
saying
that's all i'm saying until sunset when
it's not heating the earth at all not
your side of the earth at least right so
okay so i'm going to explain also my
explanation was correct okay but not for
why not
not for why yes but no yes but no i got
you all right here it goes it was a
valiant effort okay
so the sun emits a lot of bands of light
but primarily emits light in the visible
part of the spectrum and we all know
that those are the colors of the rainbow
yes one of my favorite stories and it's
not a story one of my favorite
recountings that you have done and i
believe you did on the first season of
cosmos was the scientist who was
measuring the light and then outside of
the
spectrum that he was recording there was
a temperature change
and he knew then because of that that
there had to be
a light that we don't
know or see
that is making this change i love that i
just love that recounting and he said it
in his very sort of 18th century flurry
called it light unfit for vision
light unfit from is that cool yeah he
discovered infrared light and it was
william herschel who did william hersl
yes yeah all right so here's the thing
the so the sun emits infrared which we
can't see it and it's ultraviolet which
we can't see and both of those are bands
of light outside of the bands we do see
so it's red orange yellow green blue
violet all right
and the roy g biv and the sun peaks
right there in the middle between yellow
and green all right so
so more energy comes from the sun right
there in yellow and green than in any
other part of the spectrum all right
the fact that you can see the sun
through the atmosphere
means the air
is not absorbing any of that energy
well if the air is not abs because you
can see the sun it got through the
atmosphere to the body to the base of
the atmosphere where your eyeballs are
so now what so the light comes all the
way through
it's not getting absorbed by the
atmosphere it hits the ground
and the ground absorbs the sunlight ah
not the air
okay so now the ground absorbs the the
the yellow light and the green light and
the blue light and the red light absorbs
it all
that heats the molecules on earth's
surface then the molecules
re-radiate that same energy but in a
different
part of the spectrum
interesting it re-radiates it as
infrared
and the infrared
gets absorbed by the atmosphere
so there's a time delay
right between when the sun is slamming
us with visible light
and when earth's surface responds
back with infrared heating the air now
you put the thermometer in the air you
say oh the temperature is going up did
it go up at high noon no
no it took a couple hours
wow for that to build that so i i had to
see kids
this is why you got to go to school
okay this way you got to go to the
learning centers you can actually learn
things the proper way
done yet okay get out
so
if that's the case that means the
farther away you are
from earth's surface right the cooler
it's the cooler it's going to be right
you ever go from sea level to a mountain
top oh god yes it's lovely okay the
temperature drop what a refreshing climb
okay
you say no i've never hiked it i've not
taken a
tram but i'm not hiking but so generally
it's cooler on mountain tops because
it's farther away from the general earth
surface that's there not only that if
you go up in an airplane
well forget it if you ever looked at the
temperature gauge that sometimes they
show in the front of the you know at the
bulkhead you'll see the temperature drop
be 40 below zero yeah exactly just a few
miles up why is it so cold up there is
it because you're closer to space no
no it's because you're farther away from
where the sunlight is actually doing the
heating and that's right above the
earth's surface in fact in meteorology
there's a rule about how high above
earth's surface you have to put the
thermometer so that everybody can get a
consistent reading
interesting it's nice it's not directly
above the ground you got to pull it up a
little so there's some mixing of the air
so that everybody can get a nice
consistent sensible reading of the
temperature
i love that i'm not done yet oh get out
okay so now watch
infrared do you know what traps infrared
greenhouse gases
uh-oh do you know what
the predominant number one greenhouse
molecule in the atmosphere is uh water
vapor water vapor
yeah the water molecule okay so let's do
an experiment
let's take away the water molecules from
where you are there's a word for such
places what are they called
deserts deserts thank you so the
temperature rises in mid-afternoon in
the desert then the sun sets
what happens to that heat that the
ground had accumulated from the sun
it gets re-radiated as infrared does it
get trapped no
no it escapes and the nighttime
temperature in the desert plummets yes
and that is the weirdest thing about the
desert is you will die of a sunstroke
during the day and you will die of
overexposure
hypothermia at night hypothermia you
gotta be ready for a 40 degree
range of temperature
from maximum heating in the afternoon at
maximum warming of the air to when
everything just radiates away
and by the way when there's no sun
you're just losing heat so therefore the
coldest time of the day is when
i'm going to say in the well the coldest
time of the day of the 24-hour day when
is it
um
12 midnight or
9 o'clock in the morning 3 o'clock in
the morning just before sunrise
oh yeah because there's been no sun off
there's been no sun it's been cooling
off the whole time
take a look at temperature plots all
right exactly okay it'll peak in the mid
afternoon and it'll no matter where you
are it'll do that and then it'll go to
its lowest point just before sunrise and
then the sun starts giving you the
energy again see that's i i got to stop
overthinking things because i'm talking
to you and i'll i'll start overthinking
i get basic questions i'm not trying to
these aren't trick questions i know
okay
but it's still yeah but you're right
yeah that the son has not been present
all that time it makes sense that just
before the reappearance of the sun that
would be the coldest time correct and i
got to correct something that people
have gotten wrong
okay they'll say
when is the darkest time of night
just before the dome no see that's
[ __ ] okay
okay sorry
all right anytime it is not twilight you
are basically equally as dark the entire
night no matter what so yeah
so you want to pick midnight if you want
fine all right but that whole time you
are good to go none of this the darkest
is just before it's gone
yeah it's just [ __ ] right right yeah
right exactly that's like saying it's
the darkest in the room just before i
turn on the light well it was dark that
whole time before you turn on the light
right exactly yeah
all right so
but wait i'm not done
there are certain places like hawaii
and iceland
where
the range from the high to the low
temperature in any 24-hour period is
very narrow
check out the the the climate data for
those two i know this for a fact but go
ahead and so why
oh i don't know i i just used to stay in
hawaii for a bit i spent a few months
living there
yeah like 76 in the daytime and maybe 68
at night yeah
you know and so that's because they're
in the middle of the oceans
and the ocean has very high humidity
that stabilizes
the the
the flow of the heating between day and
night oh i gotcha it slows it down so so
you heat your so the
i've done this even as a new york city
resident okay
the way you want to minimize the
temperature drop is you have a perfectly
uh a sunny day
then at sunset
moist clouds come in
then they'll trap the heat you hold the
heat they'll hold the heat overnight
that's hot
i mean that's cool i mean
that's great
so this is why you get huge temperature
swings
in in the deserts why you don't in humid
climates the tropics and of course in
island nations it's also why it's hotter
a couple hours after the middle of the
day
than right at the middle of the day and
one other thing
the day of the year where the ark of the
sun is longest and highest in the sky
is the first day of summer june 21st
that's right uh chuck what is the
hottest month of the year at least in
the northern hemisphere
uh august yeah it's not june
it's not even really july it's august so
for the same reason climactic
what goes on in a daytime cycle actually
goes on in a seasonal cycle so well you
have maximum ground heating in june
but there's a lag between the ground
heating and the ground responding to
this and
and and seasonally that takes a couple
of months to build not to mention the
ocean temperatures in those areas also
delayed right also
super cool man there you have it i i
thought this was gonna be a boring one
[Laughter]
i did this is i don't want to let you
down here and i i didn't title this one
this is like
the temperature during the day
okay we need a better
oh we need a better title than the
temperature during the day right right
and so and and why it's cold
with fahrenheit oh god i like that fun
with her fun with ferrari with
fahrenheit and so and like i said when
you're in an airplane you're so far away
from the ground the ground had no chance
of heating the air you were flying in
right and so it could be 40 below
up at you know five miles up where
you're flying at 30 000 feet and one
final thought go ahead okay uh do you
know the temperature
the fahrenheit and celsius temperature
scales correct you know they're
different right but do you know they
actually cross
on a graph
i did not know that okay because i
thought they were running parallel yeah
they're not parallel no it's uh celsius
is parallel to kelvin but right celsius
is not parallel parallel to fahrenheit
fahrenheit so so so for example what is
it
boiling water is what fahrenheit 212.
and it's 100 celsius what's the
temperature diff what's the degree
difference between those 112 degrees 212
degrees uh on celsius what temperature
does water freeze
zero what on fahrenheit what temperature
does it freeze
oh 32. so what's the temperature
difference there that's only 32. so so
the difference between celsius and
fahrenheit is shrinking as you get
colder
okay there is a temperature where if you
plotted this those two graphs cross
cross that makes sense which means at
that temperature they're equal each
other numerically and that temperature
is exactly 40 below
nice so when i say oh it's 40 below and
you say oh was it fahrenheit or
temperature i might just mess with your
head make a difference doesn't matter
doesn't matter so-called doesn't matter
this gotta matter and then i say do the
math and there's a little formula to
convert fahrenheit to celsius and if you
put in one temperature you get the other
if you put in 40 for one of them but
minus 40
minus 40 comes out the other side so
it's an equation at that point that
gives you the same answer going in as
coming out it's very cool yo man i'm
getting a t-shirt that says i'm 40 below
because i'm cool anywhere baby
celsius or fahrenheit i'm ice cold
anywhere all right all right that's it
chuck
that was great that was awesome i really
enjoyed that
fun with fahrenheit with fahrenheit you
got it start talk explain it keep
looking up
[Music]
you